il n'y a pas de faits divers sans
personnage fort le people touche toutes
les quadrigas société donc y compris les
personnages de faits divers un fait
divers avec des peoples c'est une
histoire avec des personnes déjà connues
donc du coup on a la bonne histoire
écrite tout seul pas la peine de
l'écrire elle a déjà eu il y a plus qu'à
la raconter et en plus on a des bons
personnages on ne supporte les stars que
parce qu'elle dérape c'est une star
était un vrai Dieu était parfait ça
serait insupportable et tout le monde la
détesterait il y a une demande
aujourd'hui des rédactions en chef dans
les journaux pour couvrir
le people mêlé aux faits divers people
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire des gens
bon les faits divers c'est toujours des
histoires de gens après dans ces faits
divers certains personnages ressortent
et ces gens-là ont les héroïsme entre
guillemets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes dans les locaux de Grazzia
dernier-né des journaux féminins haut de
gamme lancé en septembre 2009 qui a
particulier grazia est aussi le seul
féminin à traiter de faits divers l'idée
en est venu un jour au chef des infos du
magazine
moi personnellement j'ai envie de j'ai
envie de lire ça ça m'intéresse voilà ça
et puis ça plaît aux lectrices
une vraie attente sans tomber dans leur
espèce de populisme tu vois mais les
gens ils ont envie de dire des histoires
et les fait divers c'était le type de
sujet sur lequel tu peux le mieux
raconter des histoires
pas trop trash pas rentrer dans les
détails des gens il y a des faits un peu
sordides qu'on passe volontairement sous
silence parce qu'on n'est pas on n'a pas
envie de crapouteur raconter
on n'a pas envie de voir la scène de
crime comment ça s'est passé enfin voilà
on est là que certains aspects de
l'histoire pouvoir être plus gradiable
possible le plus chic possible chic pour
le féminin Grazia branché pour le
magazine People voici aujourd'hui le
fait divers est partout le fait divers
fait fantasmer le fait divers revuls ou
passionne le fait divers à ces stars
victimes ou assassin le fait divers se
pippolyse à longueur de journaux
d'émission de radio de magazines télé
50 Minutes Inside l'émission people de
TF1 traite autant de people que de faits
divers une nouvelle revue sort au nom
sans ambiguïté serial people une
quinzaine d'émissions lui sont
consacrées à la télévision et une étude
de Lina rapporte qu'en disant les faits
divers sont passés de 630 sujets dans
les JT des chaînes hertzienne à 1710
occupant aujourd'hui 10% de chaque
journal télévisé
moi je crois que les chaînes de
télévision au programme de plus en plus
parce que le public aime ça
donc de la part de la chaîne c'est pas
pragmatique elle voit bien que quand on
met du fait divers antenne ça fait
souvent une bonne audience voire une
très bonne audience en ce qui concerne
Faites entrer l'accusé c'est une
histoire qui ressemble à un roman noir
un contesté du genre avec son émission
Faites entrer l'accusé sur France 2
Christophe Hondelatte à son idée sur les
raisons pour lesquelles le fait divers
marche à la télévision la plupart des
téléspectateurs viennent voir une
émission de faits divers un peu pour
royautisme et un peu pour s'interroger
eux-mêmes sur leur capacité à passer à
l'acte en tel est-elle circonstances
parce que dans un coin de leur tête il y
a ça il y a cette idée que moi peut-être
je pourrais ou je ne pourrais pas où
j'ai failli où j'ai été tenté ou l'idée
m'a traversé l'esprit
j'aime bien la nature humaine je la
trouve formidablement intéressante je la
comprends pas complètement et je trouve
que dans le fait divers on arrive à une
espèce d'état de paroxysme quoi c'est à
dire que on en arrive à
une espèce de point de rupture personne
n'a l'air de lire les faits divers
personne n'achète le nouveau détective
et en même temps ces journaux qui se
vendent bien et dans la presse
quotidienne c'est les pages qui sont les
plus lus pourquoi parce que on y trouve
les grandes affaires de la de l'amour de
la mort de la vie et que ça nous met en
contact direct les grandes questions
d'existence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avril 2010 une escort-girl fait trembler
le football français Zahia 18 ans révèle
qu'elle a couché moyennant de l'argent
avec trois stars du ballon hexagonal
Karim Benzema Sidney govu et surtout
Franck Ribéry dans le cas de ce dernier
l'affaire semble plus grave puisqu'à
l'époque des faits en 2009 Zaïa était
mineur ou comment une partie de jambes
en l'air tarifait tourne aux faits
divers sans aucune volonté de nuire
Zahia et gagnante sur toute la ligne
elle n'incrimine pas le Ribéry et en
profite pour faire parler d'elle
d'anciennes vidéos un peu chaudes
ressortent sur internet un compte
Twitter un blog au nom de Zahia DEA et
116 compte facebook plus ou moins
crédible une créature People est née
devient tout d'un coup un peu au centre
des préoccupations c'est parce que aussi
elle-même
à une certaine comment dire à
tempérament people qui qui
éclate au grand jour on le voit sur la
couverture de par image on le voit sa
façon à sa façon de poser à sa façon de
parler on sent bien que cette fille est
assez à l'aise avec la notoriété et donc
elle a effectivement un potentiel people
extraordinaire véritable consécration
pour une jeune femme inconnue un mois
auparavant le 28 avril Paris Match lui
accorde 6 pages assorti d'un interview
Paris Match faisant la une avec une
escort-girl il fallait oser l'affaire
Zahia et la couverture de match a
suscité de la part de lecteurs des
réactions qui ont certaines étaient
positives certaines étaient négatives
certains lecteurs ont été choqués qu'on
puisse avoir une prostituée en
couverture du journal même si j'ai
expliqué que depuis l'affaire profumo en
63 en passant par Christine deviégentour
la scandaleuse n'avait jamais été un
sujet tabou dans match alors évidemment
là encore match les autres en parlent
les matchs le montrent
Christine deviergeon court du nom de
cette maîtresse de Roland Dumas ministre
de Mitterrand impliqué dans l'affaire
Elf et qui s'était autoproclamé la
[ __ ] de la République et profumo du
nom d'un ministre britannique compromis
dans un scandale avec une call-girl dans
l'Angleterre des années 60 de femmes
sulfureuses qui ont fait les beaux jours
de Paris Match si le paparazzi William a
Benaim connaît bien le monde des people
c'est aussi un passionné de faits divers
pour lui avec l'affaire Zahia on se
situe vraiment au croisement des deux
Ribéry avec la prostituée etc là vous
allez avoir une couve dans match avec 6
pages avec cette femme qui a été qui
était interviewée par match c'est quoi
ça c'est bien un fil d'hiver ah oui oui
je pense que oui c'est une tendance qui
qui se fait de plus en plus Bertrand
Villegas a créé l'agence the week
spécialisé dans la veille audiovisuelle
en France et à l'étranger pour lui
cisaian a rien à se reprocher Franck
Ribéry à étrangement réussi à passer
entre
très bien elle fait son business elle
exploite l'affaire comme elle peut parce
que ça a toujours été regarde sa
biographie apparemment ça a toujours été
son but d'être une célébrité donc les
médias se jettent sur elle aussi
uniquement parce que l'autre le celui
qui pourrait être coupable à l'autre qui
aurait peut-être un frein la loi ne
communique pas du tout on peut imaginer
peut-être dans un autre pays un type
comme Ribéry on lui aurait conseillé de
s'exprimer de de dire quelque chose
peut-être que les médias français sont
pas assez violents peut-être qu'ils
n'ont pas assez traqués à la sortie de
chez lui ils l'ont peut-être pas foutu
une pression tellement insupportable
qu'il aurait dû qu'il aurait qu'il
serait expliqué donc ça veut dire qu'on
est dans un système qui protège
certaines qui épargne relativement
certaines personnalités finalement mise
en examen après le Mondial 2010 Ribéry
aura à répondre de sa relation
clandestine l'affaire Zahia n'est
peut-être pas terminée
c'est pas une histoire qui passionne la
France c'est qu'il y a une curiosité sur
le personnage de Zaya donc voilà mais la
curiosité s'arrête assez rapidement il y
a des dans les grands faits divers la
curiosité sur les personnages sur les
protagonistes ne s'arrête pas
c'est-à-dire je mettrai pas du tout à
faire dans la catégorie des grands faits
diverses hiver sans lendemain c'est end
of the story après la première histoire
c'est entendu le ministre scandale entre
les escort-girls Zaïa et le joueur du
Bayern à la frontière du fait divers
sulfureux et de la pipolisation
accélérée n'est peut-être pas l'affaire
du siècle mais à quoi reconnaît-on qu'un
fait divers à une dimension people ou
non que les protagonistes soient ou ne
soit pas connus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
selon Laurence Lacourt tout a commencé
avec l'affaire Villemin en 1984 à
l'époque jeune journaliste elle fut
pendant quatre ans l'envoyer spécial
d'Europe 1 sur ce fait divers annule
l'autre pareil un fait divers dont elle
dit qu'il a brisé sa carrière et même
son envie de poursuivre son métier
j'ai eu le temps de voir quand même les
dégâts qu'on a laissé derrière nous et
bon moi je suis désolé mais ça me
satisfait pas de savoir qu'il y a
derrière nous un homme qui est mort un
autre qui est devenu assassin alors que
vraiment intrinsèquement parlant il
était destiné à tout sa façade et une
femme totalement broyée sur l'hôtel non
pas de la justice ni de la vérité mais
de tout un tas d'autres paramètres donc
voilà moi j'ai pas envie j'avais pas
envie d'être de continuer dans un
système qui laissait les gens sur le
carreau donc je suis partie et c'est moi
d'une certaine manière briser le
matériel
l'affaire Villemin commence en octobre
1984 avec l'assassinat du petit Grégory
4 ans retrouvé mort noyé dans la Vologne
une rivière des Vosges je me souviens
encore du soir de bouclage on a pris la
mort d'un petit garçon sur les trouver
mort dans la Vologne avec les mains et
les pieds liés et
premier dès le premier bouclage est un
grand sujet dans le journal cinq six
pages je crois qu'on se souvient et
ensuite ça a été le grand feuilleton qui
a démarré qui a enflammé toute la
rédaction parce qu'évidemment c'était
l'histoire
traversée des rebondissements
incroyables et tout d'un coup la France
est mis c'est mis à stationner pour se
fait divers la suite est connue
persuadée de la culpabilité de son
cousin Bernard Laroche Jean-Marie
Villemin là-bas d'un coup de fusil puis
sur la foi de témoignages douteux
Christine Villemin est inculpé si elle
finira par bénéficier d'un non-lieu elle
restera pendant de longs mois au centre
de la faire comme il possible mère
infanticide couverture de journaux
instruction bâclée commérage et
insinuations en peu de temps Christine
Villemin devient une célébrité malgré
elle
comment vous personnellement vous
réagissez au fait qu'on puisse vous
soupçonner
cette affaire et on vous a l'impression
qu'on essaie un peu de semer le trouble
dans l'enquête parce que le petit n'est
plus là j'ai plus rien je sais pas ce
que ça m'aurait rapporté d'avoir fait ça
elle ne peut pas faire un pas hors de
chez elle même lorsqu'elle rend visite à
son mari en prison elle est traquée sans
relâche
Grégory est passé au second plan
d'ailleurs après on en parlait plus
beaucoup c'était plus la fascination
qu'exercer cette jeune femme tout était
cristallisé sur elle autour d'elle
comment elle était habillée pourquoi
elle faisait si pourquoi elle faisait ça
elle s'était l'incarnation à la fois du
mystère
à la fois j'ai du mal à le dire parce
que 26 ans après c'est tellement
horrible mais du monstre à la fois de
l'ange pour d'autres enfin voilà donc
c'était plus Grégory c'était Villemin
c'était elle et au-delà de la vue des
tarisation de Christine Villemin c'est
toute une communauté qui se retrouve
sous le feu de la rampe
c'est un fait divers qui est un
véritable cas d'école je pense qu'on vit
aujourd'hui de plus en plus dans une
société fermée chaque policier doit être
pixelisé chaque témoin doit être
pixelisé il faut essayer la règle de
l'anonymat le fait divers va faire
Grégory c'est tout le monde est à visage
découvert c'est peut-être terrible quand
on le visite 20 ans après mais en tous
les cas tout le monde apparaît visage
découvert il y a des photos partout et
match va être un témoin direct du fait
divers c'est à dire que une semaine
après la mort du petit Grégory ou je
crois que c'est même tes 15 jours ou 15
jours on réunit Jean-Pierre réunit le
clan Villemin autour d'une table et
cette photo-là un an après sera encore
pour pour les policiers une source
d'information savoir comment les est-ce
qu'il y a le suspect le criminel le
corbeau est-il sur cette photo donc il y
a eu il y a eu cette cette incroyable
c'est un ce fait divers ça reste un cas
d'école unique parce que les
journalistes étaient immergés dedans
sans voir sur le kiosque cette affaire
faire la une ce qui est quand même pas
toutes les affaires parle même pas de
l'ordre de toutes les affaires
par ailleurs il y a eu un certain moment
une traque totale de la mère de l'enfant
et on avait le sentiment que petit à
petit l'opinion publique se faisait par
finalement tout tous ces articles sur
cette traque de la mer Paris Match
consacrera 14 couvertures à Christine
Villemin en deux ans elle prendra même
le risque de l'impopularité en se
laissant photographier à la maternité
avec son deuxième enfant un an après la
mort de Grégory si elle se prête à cet
exercice moyennant finance c'est aussi
pour payer ses avocats
je me souviens d'une d'une interview qui
avait été fait justement de Christine
Villemin dans ces années-là enfin dans
cette époque là où quelqu'un lui avait
dit vous vous rendez compte que vous
avez un statut de vedette aujourd'hui et
que vous êtes très critiqué pour ça et
elle avait dit mais on croirait que les
gens sont en vieux du malheur qui nous
arrive et elle avait vraiment ce
sentiment c'est vrai qu'ils étaient pris
dans un engrenage dont il n'arrivait pas
à sortir une certaine époque c'est à
dire la presse qui accuse il faut
répondre il faut répondre d'une certaine
manière il faut trouver de l'argent
enfin c'était un système totalement
délirant évidemment ils étaient très
critiqués pour ça parce que ça n'allait
pas avec le deuil ça n'allait pas avec
l'humilité ça n'allait pas avec
l'innocence donc rien à l'aide dans
cette histoire de toute façon rien
n'allait jamais
la défense de Christine et Jean-Marie
Villemin durera 9 ans elle coûtera
jusqu'à 250000 euros que leurs avocats
se chargeront de récolter en négociant
des séances photos
epiphénomène de la médiatisation
outrancière qui a entouré la ferme le
grand photographe de mode Helmut Newton
sera dépêché sur les lieux par image il
fait peser les protagonistes de
l'affaire tel des mannequins d'un jour
et un soir moment de grâce un corbeau
vient s'échouer sur la fenêtre de son
hôtel comme un écho aux nombreuses
lettres anonymes dont le dossier est
rempli
mais surtout libération on verra
Marguerite Duras fait un reportage sur
Christine Villemin son article à charge
pour la mère de Grégory alors même
qu'elle ne l'a pas rencontré restera
célèbre pour son titre sublime forcément
sublime
[Musique]
aujourd'hui plus de 25 ans après les
faits Christine et Jean-Marie Villemin
ont retrouvé le calme de l'anonymat avec
leurs trois enfants ils ont quitté l'est
de la France pour s'installer en région
parisienne toute la dérive sur l'affaire
sur la faire Vilma est totalement changé
de métier et aujourd'hui on lutte
effectivement pour
revenir et faire comprendre qu'on n'est
pas que des chiens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pipolisation excessive interprétation
fantasmatique de fait dramatique
venétarisation d'une criminel qui
cherchait tout sauf la lumière des
sunlights telle est l'affaire Florence
Ray avec son amant et complice un soir
d'octobre 1994 elle part braquer les
policiers de la préfourière de Pantin en
Seine-Saint-Denis en s'enfuyant ils
prennent un taxi en otage l'Odyssée des
deux hors-la-loi se poursuit place de la
Nation le taxi percute une voiture de
police le chauffeur est tué ainsi que
deux policiers par Audrey Maupin la fin
de l'Escapade meurtrière aura lieu au
bois de Vincennes dans lequel un autre
policier est abattu et Audrey Maupin
lui-même touché il succombra ses
blessures le lendemain bilan du carnage
5 morts et plusieurs blessés incarnage
dans lequel Florence Rennes aura qu'un
rôle de complice mais qu'elle devra
assumer seul une certaine presse
l'appellera d'ailleurs la tueuse de
flics
la mort des quatre policiers est
absolument effroyable ils sont morts sur
le trottoir dans les bras des passants
match montre les photos d'ailleurs et
pourquoi Florence Rey a une arrive en
couverture de match parce qu'il y a un
mystère parce que c'est un personnage
incroyable parce qu'on n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment cette fille en qui a
un regard presque qui a une allure
presque chérubin qu'est ce qui a pu se
passer et à ce moment-là ça devient un
fait divers national ça devient une de
match et d'ailleurs ça ça nous a c'est
pas une qui a c'est une qui a été
problématique pour le journal parce que
les lecteurs ne comprenaient pas
pourquoi nous avions mis une criminel en
Une de match une criminelle qui pourtant
ce soir là n'aura tiré aucune balle
mortelle
spécialiste du fait divers à Libération
elle a couvert de nombreuses affaires
comme celle du gang des postiches où
l'affaire Allegra elle s'est tout
particulièrement passionnée pour
l'affaire Florence Rey
cette fille a suscité une passion
incroyable dans les banlieues certains
ont sorti des t-shirts les Fidji de
Florence Ray elle est devenue l'égérie
de révolutionnaire de gens qui voulaient
mettre le système par terre [ __ ] en
l'air le monde comme elle disait avec
Audrey Maupin et cette fille avant
d'aller demander au braquage avec son
amoureux c'était taillé les cheveux à la
sauvageonne comme ça avec des ciseaux et
tout un peu un peu toute guingua et et
elle avait un air un peu un peu buté et
donc cette photo a fait le tour du pays
elle a reçu des milliers de lettres
qu'elle a pas ouvertes elle a demandé à
son avocat de les de les cramer moi j'ai
reçu des cassettes de la musique des
cadeaux pour Florence Rey c'était un
délire
les hommages se multiplient de façon
presque imperceptible Claude Chabrol
dans la cérémonie fait un clin d’œil à
la fée en glissant dans les mains
d'Isabelle Huppert un journal avec
Florence en couverture c'était pour
faire comprendre au spectateur le
principe de la folie à deux c'est qui
qui est une chose extrêmement importante
dans le fait divers c'est-à-dire que le
la folie à deux c'est c'est
des actes qui accomplissent des
individus mais quand ils sont par deux
c'est s'ils étaient seuls ils ne les
accomplirait pas et et
Florence s'était exactement ça et et
j'ai voulu montrer que c'était ce genre
de ce genre de folie qui qui allait
amener les deux les deux filles ça ne
marche pas effectivement la cérémonie se
terminera mal par un massacre collectif
perpétré par les personnages qui
incarnent Isabelle Huppert et Sandrine
Bonnaire
[Musique]
mais il n'y a pas que le cinéma qui
s'inspire de l'affaire roman bande
dessinée pièce de théâtre ou musicien
comme les Anglo-Saxons de The Kills ou
MC Solaar rente hommage au couple
remaupin
au concret je veux pas être à Florence
vrai mais pour son avocate la réalité du
personnage Florence Rey était à son lieu
de cette marchandisation soudaine j'ai
connu Florence Rey à peu près deux mois
après les faits
et évidemment j'avais l'image d'une
espèce de passionnats dont la presse cet
effet L'Echo et donc j'avais des idées
assez préconçues en venant la voir et
puis donc je suis arrivée à
Fleury-Mérogis et puis j'ai découvert
une petite chose
toute fragile toute timide et c'est vrai
que j'étais très surprise parce que
c'était pas du tout l'image que
j'attendais enfin à laquelle je
m'attendais finalement elle est pas elle
est pas si extraordinaire que ça cette
jeune fille et d'ailleurs elle s'est
plainte à un moment donné de qu'on lui
donne tant d'importance elle ne se
rendait même pas compte la veille du
procès qu'on allait parler d'elle moi je
j'étais allée voir ses avocats pour
avoir des éléments sur ce qu'elle
faisait en prison faire un portrait
d'elle à publier le jour de l'ouverture
de son procès d'assise à Paris et elle
disait mais je veux pas qu'on parle de
moi elle se rendait même pas compte de
l'intérêt médiatique
en France effectivement elle avait honte
elle avait honte de d'être célèbre pour
des faits comme ça il aurait préféré
devenir célèbre pour des choses quand
même beaucoup plus à voixables
meurtrière de Florence et de son amant
une affiche du film d'Oliver Stone
Turner avait été retrouvé dans le squat
qu'ils occupaient l'histoire d'un couple
de tueurs à vide de médiatisation il
n'en faudra pas plus à certains
journalistes pour comparer le couple qui
a fait un carton sanglant place de la
Nation et celui du film
[Musique]
elle n'avait rien à voir avec les
personnages de Turner mais je pense que
bon c'est vrai que le film tueur n'est à
l'époque des peigné peut-être une
certaine jeunesse et c'était facile de
faire coller une jeune fille avec un
jeune homme qui avait donc commis des
faits tel qu'on les connaît et puis de
faire coller avec peut-être une image de
cinéma ou voilà c'est c'est le côté un
petit peu négatif si j'ose dire de la
presse
j'ai vraiment eu le sentiment qu'en
arrivant au procès les jeux étaient
presque fait en fait
il y avait des articles dans tous les
sens
mais allant toujours dans le même sens
c'est vrai qu'on arrivait avec Henri
Leclerc à devoir défendre une espèce de
fioribles une tueuse quoi c'était pas le
cas entre tueur sans foi ni loi il y a
un archiste romantique Florence Rey et
au drymopin auront alimenté les
spéculations pendant de longs mois au
procès les ressorts éventuellement
romanesques de leur cavale n'auront pas
droit de citer et Florence Rey et copra
de 20 ans de prison enfermé pendant 15
ans elle est sortie en 2009 c'est pas du
tout une affaire romantique simplement
parce que les gens voient un crime
commis ou décrit une série de crimes
commis par des jeunes gens un couple etc
qui qui partent comme ça
oui ça peut évoquer chez certains une
certaine folie amoureuse enfin une
certaine
le bandage romantique mais en fait non
pas du tout donc ça c'est vraiment une
déformation et ne réinterprétation de la
réalité par les médias par les écrivains
par les gens qui ont fait un crime
romantique qu'est-ce qu'un crime
romantique de crimes romantique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
romantique l'histoire d'amour tragique
entre Bertrand Cantat et Marie
Trintignant là pourtant été jusqu'au
moment fatal nous sommes à Vilnius en
Lituanie fin juillet 2003 le couple qui
se veut une passion réciproque s'est
retrouvée sur le tournage de Colette que
tourne la mère de marine Nadine
Trintignant pour France 2 un soir où le
couple se dispute à son hôtel Bertrand
Cantat frappe violemment Marie qui
succombra quelques jours plus tard à ses
blessures en une poignée de secondes une
histoire d'amour fou avéré au cauchemar
le fait divers le plus people de la
décennie va défrayer la chronique
Frédéric vésar et Stéphane boucher
travailler à l'époque pour le Parisien
il furent parmi les premiers
journalistes à se rendre sur les lieux
quand j'étais dans l'avion en partance
pour Vinus on a j'avais assez peu
d'informations mais on avait l'essentiel
c'est à dire qu'il y avait eu une
dispute que elle était quasi perdue et
que lui était en garde à vue et je me
suis dit dans l'avion qui m'amenait pour
Vilnius que c'était quand même une
affaire avec des ingrédients hors du
commun
que je pense que j'aurais pas d'autre à
faire de ce niveau là avec une telle
portée émotionnelle à traiter dans toute
une carrière je pense
c'est assez unique de voir tout d'un
couple que le meurtrier et la victime
sont sont de stars ça c'est une
situation un petit peu unique et tout
d'un coup arrive deux clans d'un côté
vous avez vous avez les clés
à Londres puisque Marie a eu plusieurs
plusieurs hommes dans sa vie vous avez
les parents qui sont aussi
nadines et Jean-Louis Trintignant qui
sont des grandes personnages français de
l'autre côté vous avez le clan le clan
Kanta avec les musiciens de de Noir
Désir mais l'une des raisons pour
laquelle le fait divers va grandir dans
le journal c'est parce qu'il y a ces
deux personnages très forts qui sont des
gens que tout le monde connaît et puis
parce qu'il y a parce qu'il y a aussi
cette l'absurdité de la situation un
antagonisme qui va se poursuivre pendant
le procès un procès à l'issue duquel
Bertrand Cantat sera condamné à 8 ans de
prison quand a été à ce moment-là un
homme complètement détruit l'image de
Quentin arrivant dans le bloc avec son
pull trop grand moi j'avais l'occasion
de voir sur scène de l'argent avec
flamboyant avec une extraordinaire
charisme incroyable de gamin engrossé
dans son pull complètement shooté sur
les médicaments c'était assez étonnant
il y avait une haine perceptive dans
cette salle quoi qui était qui était
très prenante donc c'était difficile de
pas de pas rentrer là-dedans c'était un
procès assez étrange assez théâtre quand
on est journaliste notamment dans la
presse populaire une affaire avec des
ingrédients comme ça c'est sûr que
évidemment on saute dessus après elle
nous touche tous que ça soit journaliste
pas journaliste ou simplicitoyens donc
il a fallu essayer de d'être de
travailler tout objectivité de pas aller
vers la passion aussi parce qu'on a
forcément un addition l'histoire mais ça
a été je pense une expérience
journalistique assez intéressante et
puis ça a mis tout le monde dans la
boucle ça soit les journalistes de média
de spectacle de faits divers voilà de
société donc ça ça a touché tout le
monde en fait c'est mais je pense que
dans l'ensemble après ça a été malgré
les le côté passionnel de la faire a été
plutôt dans cette affaire quoi qui est
pu en dire certains protagonistes
que s'est-il passé à l'hôtel domina ce
soir là l'affaire occupera toute la
presse pendant l'été 2003 et en tout
premier lieu les journaux people
il y a un mystère qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé qu'est-ce qui a eu dans la tête de
Bertrand Cantat parce qu'elle a est-ce
que Marie Trintignant a reçu autant de
coups qu'on le dit donc il y a un
feuilleton il y a des questionnements
qui se qui se développent sur des sujets
qui sont
ultra connus et ultra populaire donc
quelque part effectivement c'est une
c'est une affaire idéale si je puis dire
pour la presse people en dérapant dans
la rubrique faits divers Bertrand Cantat
et sa victime Marie Trintignant
deviennent alors l'espace d'une sur
médiatisation galopante de simples
people dont l'opinion publique va
s'emparer c'est vrai dans cette affaire
vous avez raison de dire qu'ils étaient
certainement sur un statut de star qui
sont descendus entre guillemets du côté
du people et ça ça s'explique en fait
par plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que
ce sont deux personnes connues déjà et
donc ça en fait la presse people préfère
toujours avoir deux personnes connues
alors après il va y avoir plusieurs
choses qui vont faire buzzer le people
en fait et faire que le récit people
continue en général c'est les vacances
évidemment les enfants les disputes les
séparations les retrouvailles et toutes
ces choses là tous ces récits en fait le
poids le travail mais surtout les amours
dans le cas d'humeur très évidemment
c'est c'est horrible à dire mais la mort
est ce qui d'abord qui ce qui rapproche
également du public puisque ça nous
arrive tout un jour et que on a se pose
tous des questions là-dessus donc c'est
malheureusement un sujet tentant et un
sujet plaisant et c'est hélas pour les
médias le sujet qui marche le mieux
dernier épisode d'un feuilleton qui
mélange tragédie et people le suicide en
janvier 2010 de la mère des deux enfants
de Bertrand Cantat Christina radis
[Applaudissements]
loin de la tragédie quant à Trintignant
certains people pointe à la rubrique
fait divers parfois pour des broutilles
montées en épingle par les tabloïdes et
que cette vitesse alcool au volant
comportement provocateur c'est people
semble franchir les limites uniquement
pour que l'on parle de elles ont pour
nom Lindsay Lohan Paris Hilton Britney
Spears ou encore Naomi Campbell et leurs
écarts de conduite font plus souvent
parler que leurs performance il suffit
de conduire comme Lindsay Lohan bourré
ou de de d'insulter comme Naomi Campbell
son personnel de maison et voilà comme
ça on se fait
remarquer plus ou moins volontairement
et on est toujours dans les dans les
médias
mais parfois la pipolisation assez
limite et suscite l'agressivité comme
ici avec Britney Spears s'acharnant
contre une voiture de paparazzi
la célébrité c'est quelque chose de très
particulier qui vous fait ne plus
toucher terre vous avez plus de plus de
limites et n'ayant plus de limite
personnelle vous ne voyez plus les
limites collectives qui sont celles
fixées par la loi du coup effectivement
il n'est pas il est presque naturel que
les people dérape et si nos propres
journaux people sont truffés des
frasques de ces starlettes c'est parce
qu'il n'y a aucun risque éditorial
pratique de faire des couvertures sur
Britney Spears ou Paris Hilton des
personnalités américaines parce que
t'attaquent pas la presse française
contrairement aux Français donc on
préférera toujours faire une couverture
un peu limite sur un people américain
c'est beaucoup plus facile ça c'est
vraiment la raison la plus simple mais
la plus véridique et juridique en fait
parce que maintenant les titres veulent
vraiment pas avoir le minimum de procès
et d'autre part des personnes comme ami
Winehouse ou Paris Hilton et Britney
Spears bien sûr alimente leur vie voilà
tout le temps de petites choses comme ça
la prison pour Paris Hilton Britney
Spears qui se rase les cheveux devant 30
paparazzi elle-même en fait elle crée
son propre récit il y a rien à faire que
juste à suivre et et donc en effet c'est
du petit fait divers entre guillemets
mais ça marche très bien et ça vend et
ça vend très très bien
et sociologue à l'Université de Genève
elle est l'une des rares universitaires
à avoir travaillé sur les relations
entre faits divers et people le fait
divers à l'intérieur des nouvelles
people a toujours existé ce qui me
paraît plus nouveau et
relativement
contemporain c'est ce que nous on a
appelé le phénomène des trajectoires
trash c'est-à-dire que on a 6 sur un
certain nombre de célébrités qui
connaissent le contraire d'une sexy
story après avoir gravi toutes les
marches de la célébrité du succès ces
célébrités là dégringolent et
redescendent une à une les marches du
succès dans une espèce de uns success
story et la presse en rapporte chacune
des étapes l'une après l'autre on a vu
apparaître ce genre de trajectoire en
particulier chez des jeunes femmes ces
dernières années que ce soit Britney
Spears Amy Winehouse Lindsay Lohan ou
Samina série en chant francophone qui
sont donc ces célébrités qu'on montre
comme perdant tout ce qu'elles avaient
gagné au fond ces stars viennent
incarner les incertitudes du monde
contemporain et là je dirais qu'il y a
fait diversification du people plutôt
dans ce sens-là c'est qu'on voit de plus
en plus apparaître ces histoires à long
terme de la l'Ascension et de la chute
d'une célébrité
grandeur et décadence d'une célébrité
c'est en résumé ce qui est arrivé au
cinéaste Roman Polanski retenu en Suisse
pendant 10 mois dans l'attente d'une
possible extradition aux États-Unis
inculpé de viol sur mineur
une affaire sur laquelle était revenue
en 2008 le documentaire wanted un
desired
[Musique]
Israël
quelque part par la justice des années
après avec la question mon Dieu est-ce
que il va faire de la prison est-ce
qu'il va être axé
tout ça ça crée c'est le registre de la
peur et ce registre là ce levier là est
important dans la presse people des
hordes de photographes et de caméraman
devant la résidence où était assigné
romane Polanski une image qui soulevait
alors une question impliquée dans un
fait divers un people est-il au regard
de la loi un individu comme un autre
c'est le problème du people qui achète
quelque chose dans le commerce il y a
des commerçants qui voulaient faire un
cadeau parce qu'il est People est connu
pensant qu'il y aura de la pub derrière
ou je sais pas quoi et puis il y a
d'autres qui vont le mettre un prix plus
cher parce qu'il est supposé avoir plus
d'argent que les autres la justice doit
pas se comporter comme ça la justice
doit être équitable pour tout le monde
et quel que soit la qualité des gens
jusqu'à sa libération inattendue en
juillet 2010 Roman Polanski a reçu le
soutien d'une grande partie du monde
culturel et artistique mais pas sûr que
la réaction quasi unanime du gotha du
showbiz et servi la cause du cinéaste
qui est certain c'est que le fait divers
origin a été renforcé et c'est là que le
people intervient par toute une série
d'interventions qui sont doute en plus
des servir aux mains de Polanski qu'ils
ne l'ont favorisé notamment de d'un
certain nombre de célébrités qui sont
venus à son secours en évoquant des
arguments très rapidement comme ça et
qui au fond
a fonctionné comme défense de quelqu'un
qui fait partie du même monde et je
pense que c'est en partie ça qui a
déclenché la contre-réaction et qui a
déclenché la violence des attaques
inverse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on reste en Suisse pour se pencher sur
un cas très particulier celui de
l'assassinat du banquier Edouard Stern
par sa maîtresse Cécile Brossat en
février 2005 les ingrédients sont
sulfureux un financier international
retrouvé mort tué de quatre balles le
corps gainé d'une combinaison à LaTeX un
déguisement sadomaso la fin d'une
liaison tumultueuse comme il sera dit au
procès dans laquelle Cécile Brossard
aurait été la proie d'un homme humiliant
harcelant et cruel l’accusé ne sera
condamné qu'à 8 ans de prison
une affaire qui a inspiré à l'écrivain
Régis Geoffrey un livre sévère et voilà
comment un homme d'affaires uniquement
connu des cénacles de la finance devient
une fois mort impossible people dont on
décortique les pratiques sexuelles
est intéressante parce que la dimension
People est peut-être moins évidente à
l'origine c'est effectivement une
personnalité qui appartenait à une
certaine élite dont on avait parlé même
si on en avait pas parlé comme on parle
des people habituellement mais dont on a
commencé à parler au moment de de sa
mort et des suites de sa mort en
reprenant un certain nombre d'éléments
qui sont typiques du traitement people
la description d'un monde enviable d'un
monde privilégié qui est tout à coup
rattrapé par le sordide par par la
transgression on a des transgressions
morales des transformations légales bref
par le fait divers dans sa nature
transgressive absolue au fond
[Musique]
le fait que ces histoires prennent en
fait c'est que on fait accéder à un
grand très grand public des récits des
récits autour des gens riches des
personnes qui ne sont pas de notre
milieu et donc c'est une sorte de
satisfaction aussi qu'on essaie de
convoquer chez les gens qui regardent ça
qui lisent ça c'est tiens tu vois eux
aussi ont des problèmes eux aussi tu
vois ça finit toujours mal ces histoires
là du coup c'est vraiment rassuré une
population rassurer le grand public en
essayant de dévoiler des choses
auxquelles on n'aurait pas accès et donc
ces personnes là sont plus intéressantes
que d'autres du moins pour les médias
parce que il y aurait c'est comme s'il y
avait quelque chose à cacher parce
qu'ils ont de l'argent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en novembre 2004 disparaissait la fille
de l'acteur Roland Giraud Géraldine
Giraud et sa compagne CATIA herbier les
deux corps seront retrouvés calcinés
dans le jardin de Jean-Pierre treber
gare de chasse emprisonné mis en examen
pour le double meurtre très bercerva
dans septembre 2009 de la prison
d'Auxerre nargue la police pendant deux
mois avant d'être repris il se suicidera
en février 2010 trois mois avant son
procès dans cette affaire ce qui frappe
c'est le glissement de notoriété qui va
s'opérer entre Roland Giraud et treber
justement comme si le people n'était pas
forcément celui que l'on croit stéphane
mainca est fait diversifié il s'est
passionné pour la faire depuis le début
pour VSD puis pour par image cette
affaire a-t-elle été médiatisée au
départ parce que c'est la fille de
Roland Giraud qui disparaît oui
et certains qu'un homicide un double
homicide de deux femmes
lesbiennes
dans tout autre région de France et dont
le les parents sont inconnus
aurait pu monter comme on dit en
National c'est à dire passer vraiment
des pages locales à
quelques JT etc mais n'aurait jamais
dépassé ça c'est évidemment parce que
Roland Giraud est le père d'une des
victimes qu'autant de journalistes ce
sont intéressés à l'affaire au départ
oui si au tout début de la faire la
personnalité de Roland Giraud
occupe tout l'espace de ce fait divers
particulièrement sordide petit à petit
l'enquête prend le dessus de l'important
sous la personnalité de la notoriété de
roland-giraud on s'en est débarrassé
pour s'intéresser à la faire elle-même
et au fur et à mesure non plus se dire
il s'agit là du crime
d'un crime concernant une personnalité
célèbre mais au contraire il s'agit d'un
mystère qui va bien au-delà de la
personnalité d'une des victimes
c'est au coeur de ce mystère que tous
les regards se tournent vers
l'inquiétant Jean-Pierre treber dont
tout porte à croire qu'il est le
meurtrier même si l’enquête piétinera
longtemps très vite écroué il se fait
oublier dans l'attente de son procès
avant coup de théâtre de s'évader en
septembre 2009 la situation bascule
c'est très Berre qui devient la
célébrité de l'affaire
ce qui s'est passé avec Jean-Pierre
treber c'est un peu étonnant parce que
il a plutôt plutôt bien
négocié quelque part son son
repositionnement médiatique parce qu'il
est apparu un pas très longtemps mais
comme quelqu'un de finalement plutôt
sympathique et peut-être peut-être en
tout cas quelqu'un d'innocent aux yeux
de aux yeux du grand public
il a occupé quelque part aussi tout le
terrain que ne voulait pas occuper
Roland Giraud qui au contraire dans
cette histoire a toujours été très très
pudique preuve supplémentaire de la trek
exerce très Berre sa folle cavale
inspire toute une série de sketchs de
plus ou moins bon goût sur le net
on te croit tu ne connaissais pas
ces deux femmes enterrées dans ton
jardin j'ai vu Jean-Pierre trebert
c'est un beau gosse plutôt ouais
pour le Jean-Pierre en ce moment de
petites crottes avec la police
tu fais une interview de Jean-Pierre
trevert tu refuses
se faire un max de pognon fais-moi
confiance je te jure
parmi les indices que c'est très Berre
durant sa cavale des lettres pour le
journal Marianne et d'autres que
Stéphane main cave a intercepter et
faire publier dans Paris Match le
présumé innocent entretient sa propre
petite mythologie
quand on publie dans match les lettres
de Jean-Pierre treber on fait de
l'information brute on raconte
en tout cas on laisse on laisse un
fugitif s'exprimer
et
ça va très loin ça va tellement loin que
je finis par retrouver très Berre
en guignol de l'info et
c'est super violent et demi qu'il
échappe à 300 gendarmes d'élite ouais
mais tu sais la forêt vietnamienne est
tellement dense que tu peux retrouver
personne mais pas au Vietnam il est en
Seine-et-Marne dans la forêt de bonbons
pas de lin dans cette forêt le chat à
300 hommes
je connais ce genre d'Anniviers c'est un
cauchemar fort comme un buffle agile
comme un singe il se déplace qu'en
rouler boulet et il a une vision
nocturne hors du commun non très bien il
est très maigre un peu âgé et il louche
il y a pas eu de concurrence entre Giro
d'un côté très ber de l'autre lequel
sera le plus people ça c'est du discours
quand on n'est pas dans l'affaire je
comprends qu'on se dit ça n'importe qui
intéresse d'un bistrot il se raconter à
être en compte et encore plus connu que
l'acteur maintenant toujours est-il que
Jean-Pierre treber aura réussi presque
malgré lui à accéder à un statut
d'inculpé d'exception auréolé de
mystères et de soufrebeur lui il a
réussi à devenir un personnage
médiatique en s'adressant aux médias en
jouant avec les médias et donc
finalement là on est moins dans le
people que dans le médiatisé tout
simplement et très belle c'est un
personnage qui a habité selon les
personnes qui parlaient de lui qui était
à la fois un Robin des Bois un héros
le plus pourri enfin vraiment on a tout
dit sur lui et en fait ça faisait vendre
ça marchait bien et en plus il racontait
sa vie dans Paris Match et il parlait
pas au moindre des médias je veux dire
donc il a lui-même en fait à réussir à
gérer cette image média et c'est vrai
que ça a créé du récit jusqu'à la fin
quoi jusqu'à la fin c'est-à-dire jusqu'à
son suicide qui laisse la famille Giraud
ainsi que la justice sur un point
d'interrogation qui était et qui a
réellement fait Jean-Pierre Trébert
aucun magazine People ne pourra jamais
nous le révéler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et puis au-delà de tous ces crimes qui
font l'actualité et mettent leur
protagonistes en lumière existent une
catégorie de meurtriers qui sans être
vraiment des people exerce une
fascination très particulière sur
l'opinion publique il s'agit des tueurs
en série ils ont pour nom Thierry Paulin
18 mœurs Francis Holmes 6 Guy Georges 7
Patrice Allègre 5 Émile Louis 7 ou
encore Michel Fourniret 9 meurtres
nous sommes au centre psychiatrique du
bois de Bondy dans la région parisienne
c'est la coficie le docteur Daniel
zaguri les tueurs en série connaît bien
il a en effet été expert psychiatre au
procès de Guy Georges Patrice allègre et
Michel Fourniret et il se défendent des
idées reçues sur le sujet on leur
attribue des pouvoirs et des qualités
qu'ils n'ont pas et ce faisant on prend
un risque parce que on s'identifie à la
toute puissance imaginaire qui est la
leur au moment du passage à la criminel
on les croit toujours plus intelligents
qu'ils ne sont donc on leur attribue des
désirs des plaisirs des jouissances des
motivations qui ne sont pas vraiment
celles qui les font aller sur le chemin
du crime et
c'est un petit peu ce si vous voulez
cette cette démythification qui moi m'a
intéressée
une démythification à laquelle s'emploie
depuis plus de 30 ans Stéphane Bourgoin
spécialiste des tueurs en série auquel
il a consacré de nombreux ouvrages selon
lui la pipolisation du céréales killer
n'existe souvent que dans la tête du
tueur lui-même avec les tueurs en série
on est confronté à un paradoxe
ils n'ont aucune envie de se faire
arrêter contrairement à ce que peuvent
dire un certain nombre de psychiatres
mais en même temps il rêve d'acquérir
cette notoriété d'être reconnue pour
leur œuvre entre guillemets criminels
parce qu'ils sont ce désirent de toute
puissance de devenir légal de Dieu
d'être reconnu comme les plus forts
parce que dans leur vie quotidienne ce
sont des êtres totalement médiocres
totalement négatifs qui n'ont jamais
rien construit de positif dans leur
existence donc la plupart les tueurs en
série la plupart cherchent aussi à négo
surdimensionner cherche à faire parler
d'eux donc c'est un peu aussi le et la
contrepartie c'est qu'à un moment ils se
font choper voilà certains le cherchent
même et à ce moment-là il devient
célèbre et à ce moment-là on fouille ils
savent et pour les people il y a aussi
des people qui joue ce jeu-là qui
s'expose volontairement ou qui raconte
des ce qui laisser raconter des
histoires autour d'eux parce que ça les
flat parce que ça leur permet d'exister
et c'est vrai qu'on a scarifié le même
les tueurs en série récemment moi j'ai
fait un documentaire sur Fourniret il y
a il y a pas très longtemps et c'est
vrai que c'était c'est devenu une sorte
de people du crime quelque part par la
durée avec la dans laquelle il a il a
tué ce mode opératoire le fait que tu es
avec sa femme enfin c'est un personnage
hors norme et qui est devenu un
personnage public pédophile violeurs et
assassin Michel Fourniret probablement
le pire de tous les tueurs en série
surnommé l'ogre des Ardennes il a commis
ses forfaits de Belgique en France
pendant plus de 15 ans William a Benaim
au cours d'une la photographie pour
Paris Match pendant une garde à vue
l'occasion de troquer son costume de
paparazzi people pour une tenue
camouflage de faits diversifié
voilà c'est cette photo-là qui avait
fait le la parure
quand je l'ai vu en face de moi pour moi
c'était je veux dire c'était ma cible je
veux dire c'était massible c'était le
mec que je de shooter voilà notre
mission c'était d'avoir ça tronche à
fournirait donc moi j'ai appuyé sur le
bouton je suis [ __ ] ça y est je l'ai
il va on va le publier ce [ __ ] là
j'étais content de l'avoir
fascination répulsion le tueur en série
inspire des sentiments contradictoires
mais la pipolisation prend une tournure
inquiétante lorsque ses prédateurs
suscitent de singulière passion reconnu
coupable de pédophilie de viols et
d'assassinats dans les années 90 le
Belge Marc Dutroux et de cela
face à du trou qui tue plus plusieurs
jeunes filles et des enfants on se dit
que c'est le criant celui que va tout le
monde va le rejeter il reçoit des
lettres d'amour en prison aujourd'hui de
même que par exemple en Belgique il y a
deux ans il y a un jeune garçon qui a
été tué des enfants dans une crèche donc
des jeunes enfants de 3 ans ils
reçoivent maintenant des lettres
d'admiratrice il y a des sites Web qui
lui sont consacrés de personnes qui
trouvent que c'est un geste de défi de
révolte c'est un peu incompréhensible
mais c'est une force de fascination qui
existe des séries de Killer's Stephen
Bourgoin en a interviewé plus de 70
parmi eux Girard Schaeffer accusé du
meurtre de 34 femmes alors qu'il
exerçait la profession de policiers
c'est un tueur qui cumulait absolument
toutes les perversités possibles et même
inimaginables il a par la suite
publié des textes de fiction qui
racontent ses propres fantasmes
nécrophiles sous forme de nouvelles et
qui ont été publiées
et ensuite vendus
dans ce livre shepher parlait aussi
d'autres céréales killers comme tête
Bounty ou Otis tool notamment pour en
détailler quelques pratiques très très
morbides
[Musique]
la recette en détail sur Internet rien
d'étonnant à cela il existe tout un
marketing autour des tueurs en série aux
États-Unis alors ceci par exemple
c'est des cartes comme par exemple en
France on a les Panini avec les
footballeurs
là il y a des trading cards puisque
c'est fait pour des échanges où vous
avez les tueurs en série les plus
célèbres edgane qui a inspiré psychose
Massacre à la tronçonneuse et le
personnage de Buffalo Bill dans le
silence des agneaux
si vous avez un petit short d'un goût
douteux qui est allé Fidji de John Wayne
Gassi
un tueur en série gay qui a tué 33
adolescents et qui a été exécuté sur la
chaise électrique dans l'Illinois un
article que l'on peut trouver sur le net
au même titre que divers vêtements et
accessoires t-shirt à l'effigie de
Charles Manson qui s'est rendu célèbre
pour avoir fait tuer Sharon Tate la
femme de Roman Polanski en 1969 t-shirt
mais aussi sac de plage mug taie
d'oreiller ou encore le pire de tous
body's et bavoir en coton bio pour les
bébés
le fait divers fait vendre c'est
indéniable même les victimes peuvent en
profiter c'est le cas de Natacha kampus
22 ans cette autrichienne enlevée à
l'âge de 10 ans et séquestré pendant 8
ans un temps elle a animé un talk show à
la télévision et sa vie sera bientôt
portée à l'écran qui est Winslet a été
contacté pour jouer son rôle
autre film à venir en France cette
fois-ci présumé coupable avec Philippe
Torreton sur Alain maréco l'huissier
impliqué dans l'affaire d'Outreau ou
encore Omar m'a tué des roches disaient
avec Sami Bouajila dans la peau de
Marada
et puis preuve s'il en était encore
besoin de la trait pour le fait divers
le succès de l'exposition Crime et
Châtiment exploration du regard des
artistes sur le mal au fil des siècles
présenté de mars à juin 2010 au musée
d'Orsay à Paris dans la file d'attente
d'une dame nous confirmait l'intérêt du
public pour le sujet
on a attiré par le crime donc
la fascination pour le crime a donc
traversé le temps aujourd'hui elle
s'expose au musée la pipolisation ultime
du fait divers est décidément entrer
dans les mœurs
[Musique]